كما قال جهاز الاستخبارات الروسيه ان
الجيش الاوكراني يقوم بتخزين الذخيره التي
يزوده بها الغرب داخل محطات الطاقه
النوويه خصوصا منظومه رجمات الصواريخ
الامريكيه هيمارس واضاف مدير جهاز
الاستخبارات الخارجيه الروسيه
سرجينا رشكن ان الجيش الاوكراني يخزن ايضا
اسلحه ثقيله داخل محطات الطاقه النوويه
من جهاته اكد المتحدث باسم الكربلاند متر
بيسكوف ضروره وجودي تواصل مع الوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه بهذا الشعب
واضاف مسكوف ان الشعب الاوكراني سيدفع ثمن
امداد كيف بالدبابات الالمانيه عبر دول
اخرى مشيرا الى ان الدول التي تدخل اسلحه
الى كيف تتحمل المسؤوليه
بشان مناقشات حلف شمال الاطلسي في ما
يتعلق بتوفير الدبابات الى اوكرانيا اعتبر
بسكوف ان ما سماها العصبيه تنمو بين اعضاء
الحيث من جهه اخرى قال ديسكو ان قرار
واشنطن تصنيف الذكر منظمه اجراميه لن يؤثر
على روسيا او الشركات العسكريه الخاصه
مشيرا الى انه لا تتوفر الشروط الان من
اجل اجراء مفاوضات بين روسيا واوكرانيا
من جهتها قالت الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه في
بيان ان روسيا تعيد تجميع صفوفها وان
الشرق يشهد معارك صعبه وحاسمه وان الهجمات
الروسيه في جنوبيه البلاد هدفها حمايه شبه
جزيره القرد واضافه ان النشاط الرئيسي
للجيش الروسي هو في محورين الدنيا
احتمالات نهايه الحرب قالت الاستخبارات
الاخرانيه انه يمكن بدء الحديث عن نهايه
الحرب او الى الصيف المقبل
معنى من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
ومن كيف مراسله الجزيره كاترين حنا وابدا
بك كثرن واخر التطورات الاساسيه
بشان موضوع المطالبه بمزيد من السلاح ليس
فقط الدفاع بالايضا الهجوم لاوكرانيا في
ضوء تقارير الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه التي تتحدث عن ان فصل الربيع
المقبل وبدايه الصيف سوف يشكلان لحظات
حاسمه في الحرب على اوكرانيا وانه هناك
معارك وصفتها المخابرات الاوكرانيه
الثقيله والحاسمه تنتظر مخطط مقاطعه
لوهانس وكذلك اعمال عدائيه النشطه بحسب
تعبير الاستخبارات تنتظر الجبهه الجنوبيه
انطلاقا من اهتمام روسيا بحمايه شبه جزيره
القرم في ضوء كل هذه التقارير تبرز
المواقف الاوكرانيه المتتاليه او بلا
مكتشفه الرئيس الاوكراني عن تعبئه جديده
في اوكرانيا وعن ضروره تعزيز قوه البشريه
في هذه الحرب متحدثا عن اصابات وصعوبات
تواجه الجيش الاوكراني وكذلك عن حالات
النفسيه علما ان هذه التعبئه عثمان ليست
بجديده بحيث انه مع بدايه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا تم الاعلان عن اا تعبئه تقدم
عشرات الالاف من الاوكرانيين للانضواء الى
ما سمي بالجيش الاقليمي تم فعلا همم تسجيل
بعضهم في الجيش والان سوف يتم حشد من بقوا
في الاحتياط طبعا حسب خبراتهم القتاليه
ثانيا على صعيد المواقف المطالبه بالتسليح
فبالتوازي مع تعزيز القوه البشريه من خلال
التعبئه ما زالت اوكرانيا تستمر في
المطالبه بتزويدها بمزيد من السلاح الرئيس
الاوكراني ما زال يطالب المانيا باجابات
واضحه حول قرارها الفعلي بشان تثبيتها
بدبابات اثنين وايضا همم بدا يطالب بصفحه
جديده من الحرب في اوكرانيا من خلال
التزويد بلاده بصواريخ بعيده المدى كذلك
مكتب الاوكرانيه اليوم تحدث عن ان
اوكرانيا بحاجه الى همم مئات عده من
الدبابات وليس الى 10 او 20 الدبابه فقط
من اجل الفوز في هذه الحرب كل هذا انطلاقا
من ما تراه اوكرانيا بانها بحاجه لهذا
السلاح النوعي الثقيل لكي تفوز في هذه
الحرب وانها بحسب ما تقول لا تدافع بذلك
فقط عن امنها بل ايضا عن امني اوروبا
باسرها عثمان
هذا بالنسبه لاوكرانيا المتحدث باسم الكرم
لان امين يحذر من ان الشعب الاوكراني
سيدفع ثمن تزويد تزويد اوكرانيا بهذا
النوع من الاسلحه الهجوميه هل من الواضح
ما يقصده بالضبط
هو يقصد ان تطول ازمه اوكرانيا ان تطول او
يطول عمد هذا الحرب ما سي ينعكس على الشعب
الاوكراني وهو الذي سيدفع ثمنه هو هذه في
الحقيقه تصريحات سبق وان سمعناها هنا في
روسيا على لسان اكثر من مسؤول روسيا
المتحدث باسم الكرملين ايضا راى بان الدول
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالمعدات العسكريه
وبالاسلحه عليها ان تتحمل مسؤوليه الخطوات
التي تتخذوها وقال بان همم طبعا همم
هذه همم او هذا الدعم العسكري همم من شان
ان يطيل امد الازمه وان طبعا كل همم شروط
لا توجد كما قال تيسكو اي شروط الان تسمح
باجراء مفاوضات ما بين روسيا وهمم
اوكرانيا طبعا ظروف ايضا في تصريحات او
خلال زياره يجريها الى جنوب افريقيا قال
همم انه همم مهما طالت الازمه فان فانها
تتعقد بشكل كبير وطبعا انتقد الدول التي
ترسل اسلحه وتمد كيف معدات عسكريه ثقيله
واسلحه وذخيره هذه المواقف الروسيه في
الحقيقه همم طبعا تذهب في اتجاه واحد هو
ان كل الاسلحه التي يتم تزويد كيف بها
اليوم لن تغير شيء على الارض تطيل امد هذه
الازمه تبعد اي مفاوضات بين الجانب
بامكانها ان همم تجر دول النيته على وجه
الخصوص الى مواجهه مباشره مع اجانب الروسي
والاربما هذه الخطوات بدات تنعكس على
علاقات روسيا مع بعض دول الجوار وتمثلت
اليوم في طرد روسيا لسفير استونيا بعد ان
كانت تالين اتخذت قرارا بتزويد اوكرانيا
بمساعدات عسكريه تبلغ قيمتها 113 مليون
يورو اضافه الى ارسال عشرات من
مدافع الهاوزر تقريبا كل مدافع الهوزر
التي كانت بحوزه الجيش همم
الليتوانيا الى اوكرانيا طبعا روسيا كانت
قد اتهمت مرارا تالين بانها تتخذ خطوات
عدائيه كانت لها طبعا ازمات دبلوماسيه
ازمات في تصريحات بينها وبين الدول
البلطيق وصلت الى حد القطيعه كما نرى
اليوم وروسيا تقول بان همم كل هذه
التحركات من قبل
لن تغير شيئا بل انها تزيد من احتمال اي
صدام او صدام في المستقبل لربما مباشر مع
روسيا وتقلل من فاعليه هذه الخطوات بل
وتصف بان همم عدم توصل دول حتى الان الى
الصيغه لارسال دبابات اليو بارد الى همم
اوكرانيا بانها دليل على وجود مشاكل وكما
قالب بسكوف تنامي العصبيه بين دول النيتو
خلال اجتماعاتها الاخيره التي تدارست من
خلالها هذه الخطوات شكرا جزيلا لكم من
درغامي من موسكو وكاترين حنا منك